it just turned really really bad really
quick
so we have to confess and come clean
khloe kardashian and scott disick just
pulled off the
ultimate prank on kris jenner and
honestly i'm both
mad impressed and seriously terrified
we had fun on thursday during the season
19 premiere of keeping up with the
kardashians
koko and scott were back at it proving
they are the king and queen
of pranks i'm thinking i dress up like
her
and we have a paparazzi take photos of
me
yes that's the money you might remember
last season the good american designer
dressed up as her famous mommager and
had scott direct a photo shoot
where she ate fast food littered and
smoked a cigarette
hello hey chris there is someone trying
to shop very unflattering photos of you
the plan was to have the family's
publicist send the pics to chris
saying a media outlet was about to
publish the not so flattering shots
savage right it was definitely a process
well according to chloe that first set
of photos
wasn't that believable so they upped the
ante and tried again
so tonight is the start of phase two
hello you guys hey
we need to get some actual photos that
are going to be believable
this time khloe got chris totally wasted
at dinner
so the events of the evening would be a
little hazy
i have the bartender giving mom her
dirty martinis and i have my water
martinis
that the bartenders are giving me and
mom thinks this is my first time ever
having a martini so i have to do the
whole
this is so bad then the 36 year old
enlisted the help of chris's assistant
as soon as my mom gets home tonight and
she's drunk and throwing her clothes all
over the floor whatever
to get all of her stuff throw it in a
trash bag and kim will get it to me and
i will
be in the kris jenner outfit from my
toes to my
jewelry it's all gonna match spot on the
next day coco with the help of her glam
squad
straight up transformed into chris isn't
that crazy
and with scott and a photog in tow she
made her way to a liquor store
and got to posing in a dumpster
get a little bit of the brick so it
feels real got a close-up
i found it is that good i feel like i'm
spielberg out there shooting this [ __ ]
i mean i'm killing it i'm getting every
angle i'm putting together a movie
oh yeah next up they recruited the fam's
publicist
yeah the quick quick thing yeah it by
you sure
so tmz called yesterday and they have
you know kind of following up from the
images last time they have
images of you from monday night
yeah chris's boyfriend corey gamble he
was in on it too
and lied like a rug confirming they
stopped at a liquor store so he could go
to the bathroom
and that's when chris started to freak
the heck out
i just don't remember what we were doing
what are the trash can images
you have to pass them to go to the
bathroom i did well i told you to wait
and you didn't like listen to me
oh that was a mistake can someone give
corey the oscar
bravo cory bravo i know i was
really tipsy and i'd had a lot to drink
but i always rely on cory i couldn't
have
any more security and yet somebody has
photos of me drunk as a skunk at
a pit stop that we apparently made it's
safe to say they fully punked chris and
she was distraught
af we have to confess and come clean
yeah they fessed up and chris wasn't too
happy about it
wow i honestly don't like you guys
but in a sneak peek at next week's
episode it appears they keep the prank
going
since kim doesn't know that chris knows
it's just tune
in because you never know what's going
to happen of course the season premiere
comes after the family announced that
the reality show is ending after its
20th
season in early 2021. gee
goodbye but a source previously told et
that they aren't ruling out the idea of
doing other shows in the future
and when eti caught up with keeping up
executive producer ryan seacrest earlier
this month
he dished on the family's choice to say
goodbye
in talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make and
and i know
even you know before and after the
announcement came out
they were emotional we were trading
texts and emails after the announcement
uh and you look back at 14 years and 20
seasons of a camera in your life and
think about that
at some point you're gonna say you know
we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it